je n'ai pas vraiment de but le grand
prix spécial et les gens ont fait partie
aujourd'hui on est 20e
donc sur ça on est 20e aux jeux mondiaux
c'est quand même fort on est en france
demain l'objectif est de continuer sur
la lancée du grand prix confirme et
essayer de confirmer les points qu'on a
fait dans le grand prix spécial de grand
prix sur le grand prix spécial et de
d'avoir le meilleur classement possible
c'est bien pour la france est ce que je
trouve naturellement aussi bien c'est
qu'il ya un cheval qui est venir en
france qu'ils 7-6 7/1 français avec un
cavalier français et je crois que ça
donne aussi peut-être l'envi des gens de
pas seulement dans dans l'élevage de
faire aussi un peu attention convoi qui
a marché pour les chevaux de dressage
non
oui il était forcément déçu parce qu'il
est fini 31e sur 30 heures donc c'est le
premier il est 31e l'a donc forcément il
était super déçu là je vais pas en vue
donc on a suis là avant d'arriver à la
conférence de presse qu il y avait un
cavalier allemand qui ne qu'ils ne
concourraient pas demain donc celui qui
va rentrer à sa place donc il pense
qu'il est passé d'un état de déception
la plus totale à une satisfaction et un
moment euphorique de pouvoir faire le
grand prix spécial